oh wait did we did we okay i actually
did we say our like new year's
resolution i think we did because chris
was on right we said what we wanted to
do remember what you said
yeah i mean i i remember what i said
well last year yeah i i don't know the
first episode of the last last year it
goes to show right yeah yeah yeah you're
[ __ ] good with our new year's
resolution yeah i remember what i said
what did you say about sarcastically
saying to chris i want to be on the
abroad in japan channel
unfortunately there you are
unfortunately it's happened many times
yeah
yeah it did oh you actually uh got
through with your year's resolutions
you're the first person i know who
actually did the news
cheers to me cheers cheers celebrate my
success
very good because wait that was a
i don't think i brought it
what was yours the rubik's cube dude was
that 2019. i think that was 2019. so
i've i've i've been able to do a rescue
for the past two years now at least yeah
every time like we have a rubik's cube
in the office now
joey just goes ahead and solves it so
he's been able to do it for a while yeah
it's like i don't know i do not remember
you saying that as a new year's
resolution i don't think i gave a new
year's resolution because i haven't
really been a guided like
choosing new year's resolutions because
for the past like three or four years i
just haven't been able to do that yeah
it must be like it feels bad for the
viewers you probably think that we have
like dementia or something that we can't
remember anything what we've said and
then we're like and we probably had this
conversation last year or we were like
oh yeah so uh we just don't like them so
we just decided i know i remember i must
have said something along the lines of i
just prefer like small goals i just yeah
i don't even remember what i say like a
week ago like sometimes sometimes i have
a conversation with my mum and she was
just like oh yeah when you were talking
about this i can't believe you said that
and i'm just like mom i do not remember
saying those words at all i don't even
remember what i had for like dinner like
three days ago right so it's like you
can't expect me to remember after like
was like a hundred plus hours of us
talking on this show but you just like
remember this one little details like
nah that's not gonna happen no because
like i remember talking about current
events uh joey's channel right now was
uh he's in the dire strike it's in the
dire straits and of course he uploads to
a second channel and i i see it's blown
up right because yeah even my mom my mom
sends me a message and she's like i just
saw that joey's channel is in trouble
have you given him a phone call to make
sure he's okay
and i'm just like just breaking down
crying you know like in my bed just
looping into my pillow no i mean like as
of right now uh it still hasn't been
resolved but luckily i have contacted
youtube and i'm pretty confident it's
going to get resolved so that's why i'm
not like too stressed about it but uh it
was it was very humbling when i made
that video and like so many people came
to me and was like yeah yeah i'll
subscribe and all that so thanks if you
did yeah in some ways i really like you
know if i like a situation that i know
is going to be resolved but i can still
make a video complaining you know
because it's you know it just you get
you because you can monetize yeah you
can market but also it's basically like
a week off work because i don't have to
upload that one week i'm like fantastic
right so i can't upload for two weeks
right because
guys i i just want to bring you this
content i really do i just oh i just
can't
well you know it's like it is
bittersweet to be fair because it's like
i i you know it's cool that there's been
like this explosion in sobs on the
second channel but it's like i wish i
didn't have to resort to this you know i
wish i wish it like to my chat my main
channel literally on life support wasn't
the reason why i was getting all these
subs but you know like i mean your
second channel has basically been
becoming your anime channel for the long
time for the longest time so what if
you're just like migrating the anime man
to just now it's just joey this is
exactly what you wanted all your career
it could happen but if at the same time
it's like you know i don't want to lose
nine years what if you're
epic prank right yeah right you just
change the names and pictures of both
channels
well like so joey has a 3.1 million
jk this was the uh
and then like you like tell everyone
like like there's a good you tell
everyone like on joey to go and comment
on the new joey channel
tell them man i really love this joey
content just spam all the comments yeah
nobody
no but um i'm hoping like next couple of
days it will get resolved so you can't
you can't upload for two weeks i can't
upload for two weeks no right but um
which sucks because it's like i have to
like because you know this especially
when you're dealing with sponsors i have
to tell them like oh sorry uh
youtube did uh did a big [ __ ] and now
i can't upload it it's very annoying
having to explain that to companies who
clearly don't understand like you just
upload you know yeah what's
your channel's still there just uploads
no no that's not how it works it's just
the life of the of a youtuber where you
just you just wake up one day maybe and
you just find out that uh maybe your
career is in danger and you're like oh
okay i guess uh all of this is like now
out of my hands it was so [ __ ] as well
because it i got the strike literally
the day the night i came back from
hokkaido right as well so it was like
after like a five day trip with chris
and i'm like all right i gotta just
relax now just get on my computer maybe
watch some oh and my channel's about to
die
amazing thanks youtube i remember i was
extremely drunk when all of my channel
got copyright claimed i remember that
okay and i was like i didn't know how to
process it because i was drunk obviously
so i was like i was like because i just
had a night out i think i was with god
we must have had a night out yeah i
think i was like just very like was was
was that the night that you accidentally
deleted one of your videos oh no there's
another one
but no i remember i was i was uh i was
on trip with gone and we just had like
the one night out and i was like yeah it
was a really good night and then it was
like 4am i was about to go to bed and
then my email was like could hear like
oh fortuna just playing in my head like
youtube youtube youtube youtube
copyright claim it's been fun i was like
i wouldn't even do because i like you
sober up mentally yeah i'm not sober up
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
you're like
oh i'm gonna sleep yeah your brain's on
a hundred percent like overdrive yeah
it's just you can't because the problem
is you you wanna sort it out there and
then right you just wanna like get get
in contact with someone just know that
you're in the process of it being sorted
out but a lot of the times you just
gotta wait and you just gotta make noise
and you just gotta like hope that
someone can sort this out for you yeah
i've ever told this story about what
happened with all of that
i think i mean
they're not a trash tasting yeah oh okay
so yeah like twice now all of my channel
has been claimed the same reason twice
yeah right right so
i use using this outro song
that i think i heard what did i get i
think i put it on skye williams's
channel which is like that's a [ __ ]
yeah yeah
this he used it as his outro yeah i
thought i like that and also i was like
i had like a hundred subs so i thought
it's okay if i just like take the same
outro of course because no one's gonna
see it and then obviously like people
saw it oh my god william i loved it
because he was a banger
such a banger in fact that i had to buy
a license
and i didn't know there was an original
original song i just thought that it was
just this one song right so you had the
remix version so i had the remix version
right and i didn't know that it was uh a
remix right so i went to the artist who
made it and this song had a lot of views
it was called like uh
uh do it for love or something all right
and um
i had this and i'd use this on every
single video oh yeah it's your outro
yeah yeah and of course
i i this this come to bite me in the ass
i i didn't just play it when the video
ended it was like it would like fade
into the video yeah yeah yeah yeah so
this will this will come back to bite me
later
um
so
i got in like 2000 maybe 17 or 16 i got
i want to say 80 of my channel copyright
claimed yeah and this is on the old
system as well where it wouldn't tell
you which i think it didn't tell you
which time it was copyright claimed it
would just say you've been copyright
claimed this is the thing yeah
and it was by a company that was on
behalf of the artist who i purchased the
license from for 50 right i bought this
license back then i thought holy [ __ ]
this is so much money oh my god this is
how much licenses cost
it's like a whole month on youtube
well basically at that time it was like
it was like a lot of money you know and
this is back when i you know i was
terrified of everything and i remember i
bought licenses to fonts and [ __ ] i'm
pretty sure i'm the only person on earth
who paid for a license for a font have
you paid for winrar
okay
though just just tell the guy i
appreciate it
above the age of 70 dude i want to meet
a single person who has paid for windows
i'm going to do it on live stream i'm
going to do it live
see what happens i just want to see what
happens i'm just going to be the
computer just explode
the simulation shuts down and you just
see like the congrats like the entire
world just like disintegrates around you
showing you you just wake up
you know you know the bible story from
like like a hundred episodes again yeah
it's just that
there are people who pay for winrar and
there are people who don't god comes
down you know the flying society thing
like society everyone paid for winrar
so i paid for this license and whatnot
right and uh i i angrily emailed the guy
bear in mind i was like 19 so i was like
trying to conduct myself as a
businessman but i didn't know what the
[ __ ] i was doing yeah so i angrily
emailed him from my my hotmail account
and i instructed him that i'd purchase
this license please tell this person to
stop and so this whole thing where the
guy wrote me an email being like
uh hey you have my word that you bought
the license and i had like paypal
receipts so then i had to email this
company that was claiming on behalf
which i think was distrokid
so he had put this song in a copyright
claiming thing all right so it went
around so i had a bit of difficulty it
took a while but i eventually got distro
kid to like stop claiming my stuff right
right they stopped claiming it all and
it was good i remember how i did it it
was like this long whole process was
awful
and then all good all good i kept using
the outro
after that this is where i should have
learned my lesson and changed the outro
but i thought i'd won the battle i've
done it i've done it also the song is a
banger so the song kind of slaps right
i you know i i'd thought okay i'd proven
to some entity that this is legit and i
have the artist who you know says that
it's all good and i thought okay this is
this is it i'm good to use this now like
i paid for it i i got like proof and
we're all gucci yeah and so i carry on
using it and then maybe a year later i
want to say i don't know how long
exactly there is a there was a timeline
i get claimed
again this time like two-thirds of my
channel i want to say like and this is
right before they added the option to
mute
right right right so
like now if so you get copyright claimed
because sometimes they're still [ __ ]
claims they'll claim like one second and
then they'll say we hope we own the
entire video so just mute it for one
second yeah you can mute it or delete
the segment which is one of the more
positive changes youtube has made you
know definitely and unfortunately this
situation happened i want to say like
one month before they introduced that
tool yeah so i got all of my thing
claimed and i was kind of like what the
[ __ ] do i do because two-thirds of my
revenue just like got thanos away yeah
and this this was this happened to my
channel for about i want to say two
months straight all right so for two
months straight my earnings were like
this
yeah yeah and i lost so much money that
i never got back so it's very very i've
still to this day quite annoyed about
that um
and i i went on this whole thing of like
all right what the [ __ ] is going on so
it was like warner brothers or something
had claimed it on behalf of uh some
artists that i'd never heard of
i go and i find out that this was a
remix and i'm like oh [ __ ] i didn't know
and apparently this is like a big artist
and i'm an idiot cause i didn't know who
this person was but i never thought i
was a banger yeah right i was a banger
um
and so i was like okay
so this is weird so i i thought that he
he sold me this license and and it was
good so i i i very confidently counter
every single claim thinking i've got the
license it's all good and now i get
denied and then i appeal them as well
which is like if you lose all these
appeals your channel gets deleted yeah
so i appealed a bunch of them and for
some reason i just got denied the appeal
but nothing happened right so i just
couldn't appeal again it was weird
and so now now i was starting to be like
what the [ __ ] like what's going on like
i i counted all these claims and stuff
and nothing happened and i don't really
know what to do now so i remember i got
in touch with the guy who i bought the
license from who is the artist who made
this song i was like hey what the [ __ ]
what's going on man
you sold me a license is it good or is
it not and he's like
well i have the license to make the
remix but i don't think and then he was
like i'm not sure what i can and can't
and i'm like oh wow i'm like what what
and then i asked i asked a youtube man
who is a lawyer man who gave me advice
that was not legal advice every single
sentence ended with this is not legal
advice yeah he basically informed me
that yeah this license was like no good
yeah he's like nothing
whether the whether the artist knew that
or not i don't know he might genuinely
not have known
um
so basically he's like an indie like
artist as well
yeah yeah i assume that he didn't fully
just doing some stroke head i don't
think he can i don't know i it was it
was a weird thing and i was like and so
i asked the guy i i went had like really
angry dms with him back and forth like
so
can i use this did you [ __ ] me over like
you know how much
how much this [ __ ] me like what am i
supposed to do and so in the end it
turned out yeah like i was in the wrong
because i'd been sold this bogus license
that was like not real yeah and so then
i was like well [ __ ] what do i do now
like i've just lost like
three or four i think it's three years
of like youtube work it's just gone yeah
like just can't use any of it so scary
right yeah and so i and so i made this
video like ranting being like
[ __ ] like what do i do that's just so
[ __ ] i've been wronged et cetera et
cetera and you know and i i asked
youtube for help at the time they just
didn't help me and i was like what the
[ __ ] am i doing yeah and then
funny enough
i had a youtube partner manager before
all of this went down it was really good
surprisingly because normally they don't
talk to you right and then that person
left the company and then i got someone
new and they introduced themselves
through an email and they never heard
from them again as you know that's how
it always is
yeah and so i i went on like a mini rant
in this video being like yeah youtube's
useless they don't do anything i have
this youtube person they never talk to
me they don't help me at all after that
video goes live i got an email from a
youtube person
who was like hey of course hey i'm that
person that you were like was saying
and they were like yeah i'd actually
like to help your situation out and i
was like oh okay
great awesome
so they basically said hey so what we
can do is we can go through every single
video
and if you send me the file again
without the music in it we can replace
the video
like on the back
yeah
so i had to go through 200 videos and
re-render them or just cut out the music
because some of the files i didn't have
the original files anymore yeah like the
the adobe file or whatever like yeah
yeah luckily a lot of the more recent
ones the ones i liked and was more proud
of like yeah at that time the original
file yeah so we like 200 videos on
google drive linked in like an excel
spreadsheet and then we had to one by
one like swap them but this process
wasn't even wasn't like perfect either
because videos got uploaded to the wrong
video all right
so like so you'd click on a certain
thumbnail and title and it took you to a
different video right it was like that
was the original video yeah and then
they replaced it with another video that
got put there yeah like i did like uh
there was like a i remember it was a
attack on an attack on titan impressions
and euro nice impressions yeah they both
got swapped so when people went to yuri
on ice impressions it was just me doing
attack on type of things and then when
it was when it was the other one yeah it
was it was the other video and yeah i
sat there with youtube for like an hour
trying to explain to them what was
happening because the subtitles also got
swapped so they were looking at the
video only in the subtitles like the raw
subtitle data yeah and they were like no
no it's the right one you're talking
about yuri on ice in the subtitles or
something and i was like no no no no the
video the video is wrong yeah and i was
like panicking and i was like i was
getting tons of comments being like what
the [ __ ] is going on and i'm like fix
this did you not just like swap the
titles around
it was just weird because although the
entire video see what joey's gonna do
with his channel yeah
i'm like i wonder what the side effects
are of this like so eventually we got
all sorted yeah
you just go on the channel and like why
is this attack on titan video got your
nice comments yeah like what's going on
there exactly so all the comments are
like that's remember yuri an attack on
right so it's all weird and then so yeah
like again like two months later it
finally all got done yeah yeah and we
did it some of the videos like i said
they couldn't be salvaged and the reason
why it came to bite me back later was
because some outros in my videos now are
just mute yeah you can't hear anything
i'll say because like i had the exact
same thing uh but after youtube
introduced the whole muting thing